What do you get when you combine water with
a homemade electrolyzer and power from a car battery?
In a previous project, I built a generator
that uses electricity to convert water into
a very powerful fuel. The amount of electricity
available determines how much gas can be produced.
And using a couple of car batteries I've been able to produce over 5 liters a
minute. I've even tried powering it with a
makeshift hand-crank generator like this one,
but obviously the gas production is slower.
So just how powerful is the gas? To find out,
I've rounded up some plastic cups, some liquid
dish soap, and water because we're going to
make some bubbles. I'm pouring just a little
bit of water into this cup, followed by a
quick shot of soap .. and even that's probably
more than I need. Agitating the cup like this, will mix
the two together, and while I'm here I may
as well fill up the rest of these cups as
well. Now it's time to put in some ear plugs
and safety glasses because this next part
could be dangerous. Using jumper cables, I've
connected to my car battery to get the system
warmed up. When the gas makes its way through the
lines, you can see it pushing up through the
bubbler. Now I can take the end of the tubing,
and place it inside of the soap solution to start
collecting some gas. The gas is just a mixture
of the H2O molecules broken down into their
gaseous elements of two parts Hydrogen and
one part Oxygen. This is sometimes called
HHO, or Hydroxy gas. Alright, the bubbles have reached the top of the cup, so I'll gently remove
the tubing trying not to disturb the bubbles
too much, then use a bbq ignitor to see if
the bubbles will pop. That's crazy. Even without
a lid, the cup is completely torn to shreds.
Well, that's why I've got more cups, so I can do
it again. This one looks ready, so let's add
some fire. When the bubbles explode, the gas
burns clean, and turn back into water vapor.
There's something elementally exciting about using fire to make water, and I've just done
it again with cups 4 and cup 5. Funny enough, did you also know you can use water to make
a fire? Look for that in a different project.
Ok these cups are completely destroyed, so
I'm trying something a little different with
this last one. I've filled it all the way
to the top and stirred in a little more soap.
and  this time when the bubbles are pouring over
the top, they light off with just as much
power, but the cup stays intact. This allows
me to use the same cup again and again. Some
people might ask what the purpose of the bubbler
is. Well, it helps clean the gas, but more
importantly, it acts as a flame arrestor in
the event of a flashback like this. If that
flame were to get back inside your generator
it would probably do some damage. The bubbler
cap is just pressed on, so if there's a tiny
flashback explosion, the worst thing that
happens is the cap pops off. If the bubbler is
a little low on fluid then be careful, because
now the gas has a place to build up, and if
you were to get a flashback in this situation,
it could be a little more dramatic. It's helpful
to keep the bubbler full, so I made it detachable
for ease of use. Ok, my next test is to fill
a plastic soda bottle, and I'll show you how
to do that in a minute. With the cap off the
gas is slowly leaking out, and when touched
to a flame it takes off with quite a bit of
energy. Small bottles are fairly safe to play
with, but anything bigger than this needs
to be lit from a distance. I just made this
remote detonator pad to I can ignite larger
bottles from over 20 feet away. I have these
bottles filled with water, and to charge them
with gas, I hold them upside down in a bucket
of water. The lid gets removed below the water
line so I can insert the tube up inside the
bottle. And when the electrical connection
is made, the gas bubbles up inside, forcing
the water down and out. After all the water
has been pushed out, the tube gets removed
and the cap screwed back on, and now this
bottle is full of hydroxy gas, ready for ignition. Igniting it this way is pretty risky, but I felt like I had to
try it. This here is the safer way. The bottle
is placed carefully on the detonator pad,
and then from a distance I can fire it off
at will. Soda bottles have pressure rated
plastic that can withstand the explosive power,
turning these into makeshift rockets. And
rather than exploding, they can be re-used
over again. In contrast, the plastic on a
water bottle is weak, and doesn't survive
the blast. I'm filling up a milk jug using
the same technique as the bottles, and now
we've got 1 gallon of gas ready to go. Man,
that is powerful. I'm probably gonna to have to do that again. Wooo, nice! Nothing but shrapnel. And
that's really cool. This juice jug has thicker
plastic, and explodes with incredible force.
When I set this jug off, my neighbor told me he felt the floor in his house shake. Well,
the generator's getting hot, so it's time
to shut it down and put everything away for
the day. That's it for this project. If you
enjoy these videos, please comment and share
with your friends. I appreciate your support.
Thanks for watching.